Chris Cuomo is moving over to our side
okay Chris Cuomo
a member of the Cuomo family
the number one Democrat family in the
state of New York
Chris Cuomo who for years now has played
this far left lib on CNN he gets canned
from CNN he goes over to the NewsChannel
news nation and he is clearly pivoting
to the center actually
just the other day I was invited on
Chris Cuomo's show
and I said that I would go on the show I
or you know I tried to make the timing
work but I said that I was at least
interested and for whatever reason the
appearance didn't happen I don't know
maybe got spiked by a senior producer or
something like that the very fact that
they reached out
shows you though I said gosh I
I assume I'm too much of an authentic
conservative
for Chris Cuomo to have on the show you
know I usually Chris Cuomo just has CNN
conservatives by which I mean liberal
Democrats he never has actual
conservatives on the show wow that must
mean that they're pivoting strategy and
then I looked at the segment that Chris
Cuomo aired on news Nation I was very
very impressed it was a segment
about D transitioners
d-transitioner is not who you are and
what you are that is the role that
you're playing in this story
um and that's where it ends in terms of
people understanding your situation
do you believe that your
predicament of deciding whether or not
transitioning was right for you was
about the process that got you into it
or was it that you had a change after
transition
um I think it really came from the fact
that I since I transitioned so young I
just kind of I grew up and I matured a
bit more
and I really like thought about my
future in ways that I was just not
capable of at the time
of like the medical interventions like I
thought about like do I want biological
children and I kind of had like an oh
shoot moment because I realized what
could have been done
there and that I could have really
damaged that chance along with just like
like I said really just getting older
and growing up a little bit more and
being able to actually process what
these feelings were
it's a fabulous interview and Chris
Cuomo became the first as far as I can
tell the first person to host a
detransition panel on television news
that's very impressive
why is he doing it
I don't I don't mean to question his
motives right maybe he's really moving
to the right
could be
getting canned by CNN probably would do
that to a person so maybe it's totally
sincere but at the very least
Chris Cuomo is a very sharp political
actor the cuomos are very very sharp
political people
and Chris Cuomo I'm sure was seeing wow
this crazy transgender stuff this does
not play in Peoria
all right this is a minority minority
opinion in America that a man can really
become a woman and a woman can really
become a man and we should pump 16 year
old girls full of hormones and and
potentially sterilize them and destroy
their voice forever and this is not good
stuff okay
and it makes for much more interesting
TV by the way this is much more
interesting than just whatever stupid
talking points CNN sends down at the top
of the day you've got to talk about
Russia you know talk about how the walls
are closing in for the 10 millionth time
yeah talk about how Trump
paid his taxes or whatever yeah that's
good no this is obviously much much more
interesting and it's much more
interesting when people can think a
little bit more independently
it's a line I always quote Dante quote
Dante all the time but when Dante's
seeing his ancestor in Paradise
kachiguida kachiguita gives him some
political advice he gives him two pieces
of political advice and actually the
first one relates to the top of the show
he says uh that letting in too many
immigrants ruin cities
so he's saying this from Heaven okay but
the second thing he says is you can't
just tie yourself entirely to a
political party and make that your whole
identity you're going to get totally
burned okay ultimately you need to
transcend those petty little swallows
and become a party unto yourself
and that's true for all of us and you
are seeing that happen especially on the
left right now so what does that mean
when these people are waking up and
thinking in a little bit more of an
independent way we can win them over we
don't need to Cave to the libs we don't
need to feel pressured to vote for this
stupid 1.7 trillion dollar spending bill
that everybody hates come on
conservatives grow a spine I know that
conservatives have a spine come on
Congressional Republicans grow a spine
the things that you want to do generally
speaking are the right things to do and
on top of it they're political winners
because the people are on your side the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
[Music]